>> Bret: PETER, WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
TONIGHT.
>> NICE TO SEE YOU.
>> Bret: WE ARE AWAITING
INFORMATION TONIGHT ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL FATE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FORMER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR.
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS DOING THE
PAPERWORK THAT WILL OUTLINE
HIS RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
SENTENCING OF MICHAEL FLYNN.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENT CATHERINE
HERRIDGE HAS THE LATEST
TONIGHT ON WHERE THAT
INVESTIGATION STANDS RIGHT
NOW.
SOME INTERESTING
LATE-BREAKING DEVELOPMENTS
AS WELL.
GOOD EVENING, CATHERINE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, CONFIRMATION
TONIGHT THE POLITICAL
OPERATIVE ROGER STONE IS
RESISTING A REQUEST FOR
DOCUMENTS IN AN INTERVIEW
WITH SENATE DEMOCRATS CITING
HIS FIFTH AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
IN A LETTER RELEASED BY
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN
STONE'S LAWYER DESCRIBES THE
REQUEST AS, QUOTE:  TWO
OVERBROAD.
AS COURT FILINGS SUGGEST A
SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION IS ENTERING A
CRITICAL PHASE.
>> IT IS A CLIMAX AND A
TURNING POINT.
>> ANALYSTS SAY THE LEGAL
FILINGS ON FORMER CAMPAIGN
CHAIRMAN PAUL MANAFORT, THE
PRESIDENT'S FORMER PERSONAL
ATTORNEY MICHAEL COHEN AND
FORMER NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR MICHAEL FLYNN
INDICATE MUELLER IS WRAPPING
UP LOOSE ENDS.
>> IN A COOPERATION CONTEXT,
WHEN THE GOVERNMENT IS READY
TO MAKE THEIR FILING AND
READY TO GO TO COURT FOR
SENTENCING, THAT GENERALLY
MEANS THAT THE COOPERATION
BY THE PARTICULAR INDIVIDUAL
HAS COME TO THE END.
>> WITH A MIDNIGHT TUESDAY
DEADLINE THE FLYNN
SENTENCING MEMO COULD COME
AT ANY TIME.
DOCUMENTING HIS COOPERATION
AND SHED MORE LIGHT ON HIS
CONTACT WITH RUSSIAN
OFFICIALS INCLUDING
AMBASSADOR SERGEY KISLYAK
AFTER THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
PLED GUILTY LAST YEAR AFTER
LYING TO THE FBI OVER POST
ELECTION CONTACT FACES A
MAXIMUM FIVE YEAR SENTENCE.
WITH THE PLEA AGREEMENT
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS TIME IS
ANTICIPATED.
THERE ARE LINGERING
QUESTIONS.
THIS PAST MARCH THE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION FOUND THAT
WHILE FLYNN PLED GUILTY TO
LYING, FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
JAMES COMEY AND HIS DEPUTY
ANDREW MCCABE TESTIFIED
THEIR AGENTS SAW NO SIGNS OF
DECEPTION.
WITH MCCABE TELLING THE
COMMITTEE, QUOTE:  THE TWO
PEOPLE WHO INTERVIEWED FLYNN
DIDN'T THINK HE WAS LYING,
WHICH WAS NOT A GREAT
BEGINNING TO A FALSE
STATEMENT CASE.
ON FRIDAY, COMEY IS
SCHEDULED TO APPEAR BEFORE
HOUSE REPUBLICANS FOR A
CLOSED DOOR INTERVIEW UNDER
OATH.
AS MUELLER TEAM FILES NEW
BRIEFS ON MANAFORT WHO THEY
ACCUSE OF VIOLATING HIS PLEA
AGREEMENT AS WELL AS COHEN.
>> WE'RE GOING TO SEAT
PRESIDENT RESPOND VERY BADLY
TO ALL OF THIS AS HE FEELS
THE WALLS ARE SORT OF
CLOSING IN ON HIM.
>> THE PRESIDENT SAID THERE
IS NO COLLUSION.
MUELLER HAS GOTTEN NOTHING
EXCEPT COMMITMENTS ON
PERJURY AND OTHER THINGS
OUTSIDE OF THIS.
>> ALSO TODAY DEMOCRATIC
ATTORNEYS ISSUED SUBPOENAS
FOR FINANCIAL RECORDS FOR
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND
TRUMP HOTEL HERE IN
WASHINGTON ARGUING THERE MAY
BE VIOLATIONS OF THE